O
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Sevemez Kimse Seni Benim Sevdiğim Kadar
Elinde sonunda benim olacaksın hadi naz
yapma da Öpücem Öpücem dedim sana tip
yapmazsan da bana
şarkılarla girdim bu ne söyle o kadında
şarkıları söylüyorum biz bu şarkıları
bağıra bağıra söyledik değil mi Sevgi
sözcükleriyle dolu eğlenceli şarkılar
sandık bunları çok eğlendik bu
şarkılarda ama burada sevgi sözcükleri
Yok Bunların hepsi şiddet ve Evet alt
tarafı bir şarkı sözü değiller romantik
ilişkiler Inna bu olması gerektiği hangi
dengeler içerdiği milli eğitim
müfredatında yer almıyor kimse bize bunu
açık açık öğretmiyor Biz kendi kendini
dönüyoruz Peki nasıl etrafımızdaki
ilişkileri izleyerek kitaplardaki
ilişkileri okuyarak Biz ilerdeki
filmlerdeki ilişkileri o karakterlerin
yaşadıklarını kendimize örnek alarak
tamamen gözlemle yerleşiyor Tüm bu
ilişki pratikleri zihnimize ve sizi
temin ederim ki halihazırda normal
sandığımız halihazırda ilişkinin olağan
akışında olduğunu düşündüğümüz
eylemlerin birçoğu aslında birer Filo
şiddeti Ya
ben toplumsal cinsiyet eşitliği alanında
çalışan bir avukatım bir defasında bir
kadınla konuşmuştum
kadının kafasına kocası düdüklü tencere
geçirmiş bir hafta hastanede yapmış
ölümden dönmüş olayı bana anlatırken
dedik işte bir zamandır işsiz zaten canı
sıkkın işte ben de onu lafları biraz
cevap verdim her şeyler söyledim O da
çok sinirlendi sinirlerine hakim
olamadım kadın kurduğu herhangi bir
cümlenin onu neredeyse öldürebilecek
kadar bir başkasını sinirlendirme
bileceğine inanmış dişli Neden biliyor
musunuz Çünkü davranışının sorumluluğunu
üstlenmeye yetişkinler tarafından
bütünlük böyle ilişkilere maruz kaldık
bize dendi ki sen beni bu kadar kızdırma
saydığı Ben de böyle davranmazdım biz de
haklı bulduk bu gerekçeyi bu Halbuki bir
olay karşısında verilen aşırı bir tepki
varsa adı üstünde bir aşırılık söz
konusudur buna yönelik sorumluluk karşı
tarafa devredilemez senin yüzünden
kontrolü kaybetmedim Ben kendini kontrol
edemeyen birimde doğrusu bu da en çok
çocukken diyoruz en çok çocuklarımıza
söyleriz Sen beni çok sinirlendiriyorsun
beni çileden çıkardın deriz
çocuklarımıza Bir yetişkin olarak
sinirlerine hakim olması gereken çileden
çıkmaması gereken biziz Bir Oysa biz
böyle söyledikçe çocukta Kusuru Kendinde
arar sonra aynı Çocuk büyürken dinde
Aramaya devam eder
başımdan geçen bir başka olayı anlatayım
ben 13 yaşındayken yazdığı mızın
bulunduğu kentte kışın da yaşayan bir
grup genç bizim seviyelerde bir ergen
kulumuza pek beğenmemezlik onları çok
arkadaşlık etmezdik bir gün birisi bana
aşık olduğu haberini göndermiş Sen hiç
beklemediğin birinden hiç beklemediğim
bir anda bir ilişki yaşama teklif
almıştım şaşırdığı mı ve rahatsız
olduğumu hatırlıyorum Ama daha da
önemlisi
reddedersem başıma bir şey gelebileceği
neden korktuğumu hatırlıyorum daha o
yaşta
yine de ilgilenmediğini söyle bilmişti
aradan bir zaman geçti aynı çocuğu bu
defa elleri sargılı gördüm yine bir
arkadaşıyla bana haber gönderdi İşte
benim onu reddetmem karşısında çok
üzülmüş çok perişan olmuş ve işte
duvarları Camları yumruklamış falan ve
yaralanmış eli
böyle bir parça rahatlamıştım Çünkü bana
değil de kendine zarar vermeyi seçtiği
için ama yine de zarar vermeye seçmiştim
bu tür eylemlerin biraz sevgi gösterisi
olduğu tuzağıyla büyüyoruz bunu çok
sevdiğinden çok aşkından yaptı
zannediyoruz bu Kendini aç bırakma Allah
bilir çok içki içmekte olabilir Halbuki
Bunlar birer sevgi gösterisi değil
bunlar kişinin kendi bedeni üzerinden
bir başkasını tehdit etmesi Aslında
karşındakini üzmek ve suçlu hissettirmek
istemesi Yani kendi bedenine verdiği bir
zararı kullanarak Aslında karşındakinin
davranışını kontrol etme çabası bu işte
bu sevgi sözcüğü bunu sevdiğinden
yaptığı sözcüğü sevdiği için böyle
davrandığı sözcüğü en Manipüle
edildiğini xior bu manipülasyona ilişki
kurulduktan sonra da maruz kalırız kimi
zaman sensiz yapamam ları Beni
bırakırsan kendimi öldürürüm der takip
eder işte yine bir başkasının kendi
bedenini kullanarak Bizi tehdit ettiği
bir anlat maruz kalırız Halbuki beden
sağlığımızdan da yaşamımızdan da
kendimiz sorumluyuz aşık olduğumuz
kimseler değil
bilsem İyi de sevilmeyi de çok yanlış
öğreniyoruz öyle yanlış öğreniyoruz ki o
yanlış haliyle kayıtlı kalıyor
zihnimizde ve sonra o yanlış kayıtla
yaşamı yorumluyoruz hayat boyu en
sevdiği ilk öğrendiğimiz yer Haneler
Oraları çok iyi bakmak lazım Sevmeyi de
sevilmeyi de önce ailede öğreniyoruz
şimdi biraz kendi çocukluğumuza dönelim
Bizden önceki jenerasyonu düşünelim
Bizden önceki jenerasyonun O çok iyi
babalarına o Çok övülen koş kocalarını
düşünelim böyle bir Fiske bile vurmamış
asla vurmasına kattık cümle dahi
kurulmaz bunun adını bile geçirmez O çok
iyi eşler O hiç elini kaldır mamasıyla
öğlen eşlerin aynı eşlerin karşıdakilere
bağırıp çağırdıklarını duvara kumanda
telefon fırlattık larına da çok yakından
Tanık olduk Bu ne demek biliyor musunuz
Ben çok sinirlendim ve öfkeni kontrol
edemiyorum çünkü çok kızgınım ve çok
kaygılıyım Çünkü ailesinden çocuğunun
güvenliğinden endişe eden bir babayım
işte partinin başına birşey gelebilecek
Ya da bir şekilde kıskandığım için çok
öfkelendim ve kendimi tutamıyorum O
yüzden de duvara 1-0 lan ha ha sana
elimi kaldırmadım ama duvara bir şey
fırlatmak konusunda da kendimi tutamadım
sana elimi kaldırmamak konusunda Bugün
kendimi tutuyorum bugün Sana değil de
duvara vuruyorum bugün senden değil de
kumandadan alıyorum Cuma ama belki yarın
kendimi tutmaya bilirim Bu bir tehdit
işte korku salıyor kendini kontrol
edemeyen birini görüyorsunuz kontrolden
çıkmış birini görüyorsunuz karşınızda
Dolayısıyla bugün kontrol etti ama yarın
kontrol edemezse kaygısıyla bir sonraki
adımınızı atıyorsunuz yine
davranışlarınız bu şekilde kontrol
altına alınmış denetim altına alınmış
oluyor
ve biz ilişkiyi sevdiğinden yapıyor bu
çok sevdiği için yapıyor mu evde böyle
öğrendikçe sonra partneri olduğumuz
ilişkilerde de bu pratikleri sürdürmeye
devam ediyoruz Seni o kadar çok
seviyorum ki kendimi kaybetmişim Seni o
kadar çok seviyorum ki kıskançlığımı
engel olamıyorum işte tuzak dediğimiz
yer burası o pil asyon dediğimiz yer
burası kontrol süzün gerekçesi çok
sevmek olamaz Olsa olsa Manipüle
diliyoruz dur ve biz bunu hep böyle
öğrendik masallar Yeşilçam Hollywood
bize hep bunu böyle öğretti Aslında
bizim istismarla dair bir uyarı sinyali
olarak algılamamız gereken kıskançlığı
takıntıları sahip olma arzusunu bize
sanki çok tutkulu bir aşkmış gibi
anlattı Çok romantik bir ilişki yemiş
gibi anlattı Zaten çok tutkulu aşklar
böyle olur öyle seviyor ki işte böyle
davranıyor Dolayısıyla o sevdiğinden
yapıyor cümlesi Eğer buna boyun eğmez
Sem sevilmem Çünkü Sevemez kimse bizi
onun sevdiği kadar
bari İşte bu bir ilişkide Bir Şeyin
adını koyamıyor Sak tam tanımlayamıyor
Sak ama biraz sıkışmış hissediyorsak bir
yerlerde bir şeyler bizi sıkıştırıyor
Sao ilişki yolunda değil demektir
bu şiddeti biz doğruyoruz bazen Faili
olarak bazen çocuğumuzu sevgisiz
bırakarak bazen kendi başımıza geleni
bazen kendi yaptığımızı bazen bir
yakınımızın başına geleni normal
değiştirerek
şiddetsiz bir yaşam mümkün nasılki
elbirliğiyle inşa edildi nasıl ki bu bir
sosyal inşa elbirliğiyle de alaşağı
edilebilir ses çıkacağız şiddetin adını
koyacağız fail olmayacağız faile akıl
almayacağız hayatta kalana inanıp
hayatta kalın arkasında duracağız Biz
kendimize bunu hak etmediğimizi ikna
ettik ikna ettikçe
sevgi içinde büyüyen çocuklar
yetiştirdik Ç etrafımızdaki çözümsüz
toksik ilişkilerden uzaklaştıkça Dünya
çok daha güzel bir yer olacak Hem de
öyle on saniye yine falan değil
abone ol
[Alkış]